[Music]
the society has many rules and even
though they're not exactly official you
should still try to avoid doing certain
things in public being late taking
selfies and even playing loud music are
things that are not socially acceptable
but do you know what you should do and
shouldn't do in public we bet everyone
has done the number-10 at some point
never miss a video again by subscribing
to our Channel and don't forget to hit
the like button today we're discussing
10 things you should never do in public
taking selfies Google reported that 24
billion selfies were made during the
first year of Google photos whether or
not it's acceptable to take selfies in
public is a never-ending debate there
are many reasons why this shouldn't be
as acceptable as it is while taking a
picture of yourself doesn't really do
any harm to anyone
it really depends on where and public
you do it there are still many places
out there that don't allow photography
in general but you will also find that
taking selfies is frowned upon on the
memorial sites although done by many you
should never ever take selfies at a
Holocaust Memorial and yet we see people
even doing yoga poses in places that are
built as a tribute to the Fallen victims
sure you can do it but your picture
might end up on a website called Yolo
cost it was a project created to show
what it looks like when you take selfies
in places that aren't meant for them the
writer behind the yoga Kosh showed the
jugglers and Yogi's and the kings and
queens of selfies taking their pictures
in inappropriate places so before you
take a selfie in public make sure you
aren't doing something that's
disrespectful to the place you're at
using the gym as your personal bathroom
speaking of public places you can find
plenty of rules about unacceptable
behaviors at the gym one of them is
feeling a little bit too free in your
gyms bathroom although all gyms have
showers that make you feel squeaky clean
before you leave being an exhibitionist
might not be the smartest idea at the
at the same time neither is staring at
people who are walking around without
their clothes on in your locker room gym
locker rooms are a place where you have
to respect people's privacy
this also means you're not allowed to
body shame in any kind of way that's
exactly what happened to Danny Mathers a
model who thought it would be funny to
take a picture of another gym goer in
the showers Danny laughed about the
woman's body but she was no longer
laughing when her fans didn't appreciate
her behavior as a result Danny lost her
job and was banned from several gyms she
could even face criminal charges
Danny later apologized saying she meant
to sin the photo only to her friend but
it doesn't change the fact that she
disrespected her fellow gym goer think
twice before you get too comfortable in
gym locker rooms and make someone else
feel uncomfortable occupying gym
equipment is not using it anyone who's
serious about their gym routine can tell
you that one of their biggest pet peeves
is the people who get distracted at the
gym but they still occupy the equipment
we're talking those who start taking
selfies check emails and they might even
be on call with work bodybuilding.com
states that you should never hog a piece
of equipment if your gym is packed share
your equipment and rotate through sets
while you might not be on a strict time
schedule someone else could be so don't
keep the equipment to yourself and be
considerate of others you never know you
might even make a new friend so what can
you do when you see someone hogging the
gym equipment but they're not really
using it this gym goer shared his
experience when he confronted the guy
who frequently hogged the equipment
without using it the guy who was hogging
the equipment was so upset he told on
him to the gym staff but they didn't do
him any favors a gym is a place where
you workout but it's still a public
place so make sure you're respectful to
others come to work when you're sick
this is a never ending debate should you
come to work even when you're sick of
course some of your bosses might
disagree but the truth is coming to work
when you're sick puts everyone at risk
there's a whole scientific explanation
about
what kinds of people tend to go to work
sick the data information of almost two
hundred thousand individuals from 34
countries participated and was analyzed
to determine the reasons why people
would rather go to work sick than miss a
day some of the reasons include the
already established work conflicts and
fear to lose the job or income on the
other hand people have also reported
they enjoy what they do so much that
they don't really want to miss out
because of a sick day but whatever your
reason coming to work sick and have even
bigger consequences than just your own
sickness Forbes notes that it's
important to make sure you don't make
other people contagious as some of your
co-workers might have children at home
and other circumstances that would make
em sick harder working while sick also
makes you less focused and can cause
disruption with your co-workers you
might also stay sick for longer so stay
at home your boss and your co-workers
will appreciate it filming a show with
your phone although this is now a very
common thing to do in a concert you
should never film a concert with your
phone filming with your phone might make
you miss the entire real-life experience
as you're watching the concert through
your phone's lens instead of enjoying
what's right in front of you using a
phone might also be annoying to the
person behind you as they might not be
able to see what's happening on stage in
2016 a British magazine reported that
London's West End theatre was putting a
stop to those who are filming their
shows instead of enjoying the
performance it was said that they will
shine lasers at people who are using
their phone in hopes that singling them
out would make them stop the actor
Benedict Cumberbatch actually complained
about being distracted by them during
his monologues filming a concert with
the phone would make your video sound
horrible and you'd never watch it again
anyways so put that phone away and jump
or dance instead you're seeing a show
after all what do you think should
people use their phones during concerts
using mental disorder terms as a joke
using mental illnesses as adjectives or
jokes in a public conversation might rub
some people the wrong way
society still has a hard time learning
about mental illness but to some people
they represent an everyday battle you
should never use mental disorders as an
adjective to put an emphasis on your
jokes or dislikes one of the popular
words teens use these days is triggered
but little do they know that while their
so-called triggers are usually just
jokes and an over-exaggeration the word
triggered is very serious with people
facing post-traumatic stress disorder
have you heard someone saying that they
are so OCD it might seem like an
innocent statement but OCD can be a very
serious problem for people terms like
these shouldn't be taken so lightly and
they definitely shouldn't be used as a
joke using such language can easily
cause harm to others without us even
knowing such phrases might seem innocent
to you or even to your friends but it
might accidentally trigger unwanted
memories and thoughts to a bystander who
heard your conversation language is
powerful and we must be careful how we
use it in public being late were you
ever late for a dinner date or a meeting
this is a subject of discussion but many
have stated that being late shouldn't be
socially acceptable we've all heard the
terms such as being fashionably late but
have you ever waited for someone for
more than 30 minutes we bet it didn't
feel that good the truth is being late
doesn't have any rules and it really
depends on the event you're attending
late for a party it might not be a huge
thing but late for a meeting at work
that's a whole other issue in a
workplace environment being late could
even get you fired if it turns into a
pattern but some people have what is
called chronic lateness in Psychology
Today explained that these individuals
just really don't want to be early they
see it as a waste of time
instead of arriving early and making the
time valuable they do other things and
arrive late but arriving early can make
a really good impression on your boss
friend or your dinner days the best way
to make sure you're not offending
someone by being late is to communicate
the situation to them as quickly as
possible
what about you are you always late are
always early
using your phone during the lunch date
have you ever gone out with a friend and
notice the two of you spend more time on
your phones than actually talking to
each other you wouldn't be the first one
we live in a world where we are
constantly connected to our gadgets and
have almost forgotten what it's like to
live without them but being on your
phone when you're in the company of
another person might be pretty offensive
especially if you're on a date using
your phone on a date and not paying
enough attention to the person you're
with usually doesn't end that well the
same goes with when you're in the
company of your friends using your phone
during dinner or lunch is really
obnoxious Pew Research Center conducted
a research in 2015 and found out that
eighty-eight percent of the respondents
don't agree with those who use their
phones at a social event it shows that
you probably have something better to do
and to pay full attention to the person
you're with but there is a clever way to
deal with this problem simply pile up
all phones in the middle of the table
the person who picks up their phone
first has to buy everyone's lunch
playing loud music whether you're using
public transportation or jamming to your
music in your car you should ask
yourself if it's really necessary if
you've spent some time on public
transportation you've probably seen some
people playing their music loudly
through their phone instead of listening
to it on their headphones if you do this
you might not realize it but loud music
can cause a lot of disturbances to your
fellow commuters you might make
someone's headache even worse or even
wake up a sleeping baby in London young
people can actually lose their free
transportation privileges if they're
reported for playing loud music but
listening to loud music especially in
your car or through your headphones can
also cause chronic hearing damage and
permanent ringing in the ears this might
change the way auditory nerves are
delivered to your brain and have an
effect on other parts of your brain take
it from phonak's audiologists who said
people need at least 10 hours of break
after hearing extremely loud noise
audiologists the
and members and others who work with
loud sound everyday often have to find a
solution to prevent hearing loss so not
only is plain loud music in public rude
it can also be very dangerous scratch
your butt and it isn't it right here's a
funny thing about scratching your butt
nine times out of 10 no one will ever
tell you anything if you do actually
scratch your butt in public but why is
this considered socially unacceptable
well considering where you're putting
your hand that part of the body is
definitely not the cleanest you should
avoid scratching your butt for hygienic
reasons but if you do make sure you
always wash your hands did you know that
Jennifer Lawrence actually managed to
offend the whole Island of Hawaii when
she scratched her butt on some sacred
rocks and even managed to break a rock
in the process and led people to believe
it's a curse nope it was just too
different Lawrence scratching her but
she laughed about it on a talk show but
the public wasn't happy about it
many demanded an apology for her actions
and labeled her as disrespectful toward
Hawaiian culture Jennifer might be one
of those quirkiest and relatable
Hollywood actresses we know but do you
think she's taking this a little bit too
far lesson learned
leave but scratching adventures back
home and less you think it's serious
then you should always see a doctor what
is socially acceptable but shouldn't be
let us know in the comments below don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
give this video a big thumbs up speaking
of unacceptable check out our ten
accidentally inappropriate signs that
will make you laugh thanks for watching
[Music]